well I mean I guess the hardline
secularism is not a good idea which is
not to say that secularism is not a good
idea I mean I certainly think that the
attempt in the United States to buy
groups here to rewrite American history
as a sort of Christian story and to
portray the founding fathers as
Christian fathers is something that
really needs to be challenged and and in
the name of secular in the name of
history but accurate history as well as
everything else but I think the kind of
hard-nosed secularism of France that
kind of unbending insistence on that
secular means one thing and that
violations of it Park will not be
tolerated in any way is a bad idea
and that if you're accommodating
different groups different populations
what you need to do is figure out ways
of accommodating him the way the French
did when they passed the 1905 law
separating church and state the way they
did with the Catholic Church there was a
day off for religious instruction for
kids all the holidays in France still or
summer state holidays but most of them
are Catholic not even just Christian
Catholic holidays parts of France are
the Alsace and Lorraine the process
Moselle those departments which were
under German control when the 1905 law
was passed and then came back to France
after the war those those areas were
never forced to adopt the secular
practices that the rest of the country
adopted so still in those areas you can
have religious teaching in schools
children have to take a course in
religious instruction and so on and so
forth so if they're not even consistent
it's not even a nationally consistent
policy in relation to Catholicism which
was the dominant religion at the time
the law was passed so too
act as if it's either secularism or
nothing or that the secular and the
religious are in eternal opposition to
each other is to misrepresent French
history and to create a situation in
which there will only be a greater sense
of felt discrimination and anger on the
part of the populations whom these these
laws affect so it seems to me that that
kind of hardline secularism which is as
fundamentalist in its way as the most
extreme Islam Islamist fundamentalism is
defeats its own purpose and really
doesn't end up producing a situation in
which there can be a certain kind of
pluralism cultural pluralism and
political assimilation and political
citizenship